il y a cinq mois cela la mère a voulu
accepter nos humbles sacrifices mais il
ya une nouvelle éruption il ya plusieurs
milliers d'années la danse rituelle a
permis de conduire l'énergie et de
calmer la terre grâce à elle moi je vois
là film
celle qui a survécu
contre toute attente
sept nouveaux héros de contes y entrer
avec pour objectif de fournir à la ville
plusieurs mois de vie paisible un seul
deviendra un champion et méritera de
prendre place parmi nous
de vous c'est l'heure de mourir vous
avez trois règle à retenir dont la
battle commencera ses soit vous dansez
soit vous brûlez surveillez bien vos
tirs et à l'instant où vous n'aurez plus
vous mourrez retirer ce bracelet
et vous mourrez
[Applaudissements]
m
par ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
c'est impossible conscient vivent tous
les deux un grand classique
vous tous les élus de gauche que vous
allez tout le monde apprendra enfin si
les banques